How could Jane Foster choose a life of superheroics
over her lifelong passion?
Was this magical weapon always available to
those who don't prove themselves worthy?
And what makes Thor a hero instead of just
a god?
These are the confusing moments in "Thor:
Love and Thunder" explained.
Major spoilers ahead.
Gorr and his daughter are the first people
seen in "Thor: Love and Thunder," as they
walk through a barren desert, dying of starvation
and thirst.
All of this sets up the story of how Gorr
loses his faith and becomes the God Butcher.
However, because Gorr and his daughter appear
to be human, viewers may be confused as to
whether the scene takes place on Earth.
While the movie doesn't provide an explanation,
the comics offer some clues.
In the comics, Gorr is more obviously alien
in his design, and his loss of faith explicitly
happens on an alien planet.
With that, we can safely assume that movie
Gorr is also an alien.
When the prologue takes place is more difficult
to answer.
"Love and Thunder" leaves this to viewers'
imaginations.
However in the comics, Gorr lost his faith
thousands of years ago, and even meets Thor
for the first time in the Middle Ages.
While Thor doesn't encounter Gorr until the
present day in the movie, based on the comics,
it's fair to believe that Gorr has been on
his god-killing quest for centuries, if not
millennia.
After Hela shattered Thor's hammer Mjolnir
into pieces at the beginning of "Ragnarok,"
Thor needed a new weapon to take on Thanos
in "Infinity War."
So with the help of some of the Guardians
of the Galaxy, he traveled to Nidavellir to
ask Eitri the Dwarf to forge Stormbreaker
for him.
Thor and his allies then heroically flew in
mid-battle to join the fight against Thanos
on Earth, and Thor demonstrated the awesome
power of his shiny new weapon.
Stormbreaker remains Thor's weapon of choice
in his latest adventure, but when Jane shows
up wielding Mjolnir, Stormbreaker exhibits
all the signs of being jealous of Thor's close
relationship with his ex-weapon.
While it's a hilarious take on a love triangle,
some viewers may find themselves wondering
why Stormbreaker seems sentient while Mjolnir
never did.
The answer has been supplied by "Thor: Love
and Thunder" director Taika Waititi, who pointed
out that the ax's handle was made out of Groot's
arm.
Groot is currently a teenager, making his
former arm a teenager too.
Because of its connection to Groot, not only
does Stormbreaker have a certain level of
consciousness, like many teenagers, it's also
fairly temperamental.
Jane and Thor fell in love during 2011's "Thor,"
but after breaking the Bifrost, they didn't
see each other again until two years later
in "Thor: The Dark World."
After that, Jane and Thor embarked on a romance,
but as Korg explains in "Love and Thunder,"
soon fear and their commitment to their jobs
led to their break-up.
"Sorry to hear that Jane dumped you."
"She didn't dump me, I dumped her.
It was a mutual dumping."
While it's not entirely clear when this happened,
we know Jane and Thor were no longer together
by "Ragnarok," and their reunion offers an
opportunity for further clarity.
When Thor and Jane meet again, Jane casually
asks how long they've been apart.
"What's it been, three, four years?"
"Eight years, seven months and six days, give
or take."
Some fans may be confused about why the discrepancy
between their recollections of the timing
of their break-up is so different, but there
are a couple of potential explanations.
On the one hand, it points to the fact that
Thor has been literally counting the days
since they parted, while Jane has had other
things on her mind.
That would indicate Thor's been holding a
much bigger and brighter torch for Jane than
she has for him.
However, Jane's belief that it's been somewhere
between three and four years might suggest
she may have been snapped away by Thanos — meaning
that in her mind, their break-up is far more
recent than it is for Thor because, for five
of the eight-plus years since, she technically
didn't exist.
Is it a subtle nod to Thanos' actions or are
we reading too much into things?
You decide.
"Thor: Love and Thunder" introduces several
new locations, but perhaps the most impressive
is Omnipotence City, an embassy for gods of
all kinds from across the universe.
Yet, while all gods are welcome there in the
comics, that isn't the case in the film.
Thor indicates that their attendance at the
meeting of gods where they plan to ask for
Zeus' help to take on Gorr is by invitation
only.
In fact, they're so concerned about getting
kicked out before they can make their request,
that they don the clothes of a set of gods
that were invited as a disguise.
Still, it's hard not to wonder why Thor hasn't
been invited to Omnipotence City before.
After all, he's a god from a pretty powerful
family that's made waves across the Nine Realms.
Moreover, in the comics, Thor once went to
Omnipotence City to seek information about
Gorr's whereabouts from its vast library.
Yet, while his destination in the movie is
the same, Thor's not exactly welcome in the
MCU's version of Omnipotence City, In fact,
while Thor may seem like a big deal in other
contexts, Zeus indicates he doesn't think
too highly of the space Viking, noting that
once Odin died, he was under the impression
his whole pantheon was gone.
In the comics, the denizens of Olympus and
Asgard are usually friends and allies.
Of course, there are always exceptions, but
it seems that there's not a whole lot of goodwill
between the two pantheons in the MCU.
Perhaps that's why Thor has never landed an
Omnipotence City invite before.
When we first met Thor more than a decade
ago, he reveled in war and sought out fights
even when there was no need.
"Through your arrogance and stupidity, you
have opened this peaceful realms and innocent
lives to the horror and desolation of war."
But after Odin stripped him of Mjolnir and
banished him to Earth, Thor learned his lesson:
His ability to help people was his true superpower.
It was this realization that led him to join
the Avengers and become a defender of Earth
and its people.
Yet, the other gods we meet in "Love and Thunder"
don't seem to share Thor's concern for the
greater good.
In "Love and Thunder," the gods come across
as vain and complacent and they believe mortal
beings' only purpose is to worship them.
This is a bit confusing.
After all, Thor's nothing like these other
gods.
Part of the reason for this may be simply
that Thor's Viking background means he was
an especially talented fighter and it gave
him a skill that he could use to benefit others,
a skill that many other gods may not share.
That said, gods like Zeus used to be powerful
forces on Earth but aren't anymore.
It's possible that just as their worshippers
have rejected them, they've turned against
their former worshippers.
However, it's more likely that Thor is so
different from the other Gods directly because
of his humbling experiences on Earth.
Once he realized that human beings could be
worth protecting, he became a true hero, instead
of just a god.
It doesn't seem as if the other gods in Omnipotence
City have had the same humbling moments.
When Thor gets the attention of Zeus in Omnipotence
City and asks him to raise an army of gods
to help him take on Gorr, Zeus is unwilling
to help, arguing that the gods are safe where
they are.
The only measure he's willing to take to protect
the gathered deities from Gorr is to force
Thor and his allies to stay there so Gorr
can't learn the location of Omnipotence City
from them.
Yet, some fans may scratch their heads at
this, not because Zeus' reason for holding
Thor is flawed but because if he wants to
keep Thor in Omnipotence City, he should want
to do the same with every other god in existence.
After all, if Thor knows where Omnipotence
City is, it stands to reason that all the
other gods do too.
So even if Zeus doesn't want to take on Gorr,
if he wants to ensure none of the gods Gorr
goes after reveals the location of Omnipotence
City, it seems he should send someone to gather
up any gods who aren't already there.
That way the gods will all be safe in Omnipotence
City and Gorr will never learn their location.
It's a win-win, and since Thor is the only
god who seems to want to confront Gorr, Zeus
probably wouldn't get much pushback to keeping
all the gods in the City.
When Zeus tries to have his soldiers take
Thor and his friends into custody so they
can't leave Omnipotence City, it leads to
a brutal brawl.
Yet, despite all the gods surrounding them,
the only one that helps the soldiers is Zeus.
Zeus wreaks plenty of havoc with his weapon,
Thunderbolt, including almost obliterating
Korg.
When he attempts to take Thor out with it,
though, Thor catches it and throws it back
at Zeus, seemingly landing a killing blow
to the shock of the other gods watching.
Despite appearing to meet his demise, however,
it's revealed in a mid-credits scene that
although Zeus was wounded, he's far from deceased.
This could lead some to wonder if Zeus can
truly die at all.
Zeus is still alive in the comics, so there's
no definitive evidence one way or another.
Plus, we know that, regardless of how poetic
it might have been, Zeus' own weapon can't
kill him, which likely means no other divine
weapon can either.
However, even though Zeus is unwilling to
seek out Gorr for the good of gods everywhere,
his attempt to prevent Thor from going after
him so Gorr can't discover the location of
Omnipotence City indicates he's scared of
Gorr's weapon, the Necrosword.
So while it may be almost impossible for Zeus
to die, it seems there's at least one weapon
in the universe that can kill him.
After Gorr takes up the Necrosword it grants
him all kinds of powers that ironically mimic
those of a deity.
Gorr is immortal as long as the sword exists,
has enhanced strength that allows him to overcome
gods, and is able to create shadow monsters
that do his bidding.
Yet, it's only when Thor, Mighty Thor, and
Valkyrie reach the Shadow realm where Gorr
resides that we see he possesses one more
unexpected skill: the ability to read minds.
When the trio initially arrives, the God Butcher
is nowhere to be found, and when he finally
appears he's like something out of a horror
movie as he immobilizes them and then taunts
them with their darkest memories, impulses,
and feelings.
While his ability to use each individuals'
own thoughts against them makes Gorr even
scarier than he already was, it's hard not
to wonder where this particular power comes
from.
In the comics, the Necrosword granted Gorr
plenty of abilities, but telepathy wasn't
one of them.
Yet, earlier in "Love and Thunder" the Necrosword
appears to have the power to not only call
out to Gorr but to know that he would be a
worthy successor to the individual who previously
wielded it.
This indicates that, at least in the MCU,
the Necrosword grants its user the ability
to see into others' minds.
It may not be the most useful skill when your
goal is to slay gods, but it's sure freaky
when Gorr uses it to torture Thor and his
allies in the movie.
"Where were you?"
Outside of a brief appearance in "Endgame,"
Jane hasn't been seen in the MCU in almost
a decade, and when we catch up with her in
"Love and Thunder," she isn't in a good place.
Jane has advanced-stage cancer, and even though
she's getting treated for it, it isn't getting
better.
Nonetheless, Jane continues to work, even
sleeping in her lab so she can get more done.
While the movie suggests that part of what
Jane is doing centers on finding a cure for
her cancer, it's reasonable to assume she's
still pursuing the astrophysics work that
was established as her passion early in the
"Thor" franchise.
Yet, after she travels to Asgard, reconnects
with Mjolnir, and becomes the Mighty Thor,
Jane completely abandons her life's work to
travel across the cosmos and fight Gorr.
While the movie doesn't put too fine a point
on it, some viewers may feel this seems out
of character for Jane, whose brilliant mind
balanced Thor's spectacular brawn in the first
two "Thor" films.
Ultimately, the reason behind her changed
focus is supplied by Jane herself.
The cancer is making Jane feel weak and incapable,
but picking up Mjolnir and becoming the Mighty
Thor makes her feel strong and powerful.
To Jane, it's like she's been granted another
life.
So if her choices are only to continue to
pursue her physics work until she's too weak
to do so anymore or to periodically feel strong
as the Mighty Thor, it's understandable why
she'd choose the second option.
"Let's bring the rainbow."
Throughout its time in the MCU, Mjolnir has
never demonstrated the same level of sentience
that Stormbreaker does in "Love and Thunder."
Nonetheless, it's clear Mjolnir knows how
to listen.
Not only does it refuse to let the God of
Thunder reclaim it on Odin's orders in the
first "Thor" film, but in his fourth solo
adventure when Thor tells Mjolnir to always
protect Jane while the pair are a couple,
the hammer clearly takes the instructions
to heart.
So when Jane's cancer doesn't appear to be
improving, Mjolnir calls to her from New Asgard,
and once she arrives, it puts its shattered
remains back together and grants her the power
of Thor.
Yet, it soon becomes clear that wielding Mjolnir
is actually accelerating Jane's cancer.
As a doctor on New Asgard tells Thor, Jane
is rapidly declining, and it seems her taking
up the mantle of the Mighty Thor is the reason.
But this is a confusing revelation.
After all, if Mjolnir's goal is to protect
Jane, how is it possible that it's actually
making things worse for her?
Unfortunately, Mjolnir's options for helping
Jane are pretty much limited to granting her
superhero powers.
In the comics, when Jane uses Mjolnir to become
the Mighty Thor, it removes all toxins from
her body including the chemotherapy and other
drugs treating her cancer, while leaving cancer
behind because it's a part of her.
So while it's doing the best it can to keep
Jane safe, Mjolnir doesn't realize its form
of protection won't actually do much to assist
a terminally ill human.
It's a reasonable oversight when you're used
to being wielded by space Vikings, but it
hastens Jane's sad end.
Ever since Thor was introduced in the MCU,
a major part of his story has centered on
whether he was worthy of wielding Mjolnir.
As a result, it's understandable that when
he was forced to switch weapons, many fans
believed that same worthiness clause applied
to his newly forged ax Stormbreaker.
After all, Stormbreaker certainly seems to
be as powerful as Mjolnir in many ways.
So these same fans may be very confused when
the seemingly unworthy Gorr is able to take
Stormbreaker from Thor and carry it off with
him in "Love and Thunder."
But it won't be the first time fans have wondered
if characters have to be worthy to lift Stormbreaker.
The question was raised after Groot lifted
the ax to offer his arm as a handle in "Infinity
War," with that film's directors Joe and Anthony
Russo clarifying
"Mjolnir requires worthiness, not Stormbreaker."
In fact, even Mjolnir didn't require worthiness
until Odin whispered the words that gave it
this property.
Considering that, it makes sense that pretty
much anyone can lift Stormbreaker if they
want to.
The Necrosword has granted Gorr an unnaturally
long life, but that longevity has come with
a trade-off: If the Necrosword is ever destroyed,
Gorr will die quickly afterward.
So when Thor returns to the Shadow realm to
rescue Asgard's children and once again attempt
to defeat Gorr, his main goal is to shatter
the Necrosword.
Thor manages to get this done with an assist
from the kidnapped Asgardian kids who he temporarily
shares his powers with, and Jane, who he'd
begged to stay on New Asgard, as another fight
as Mighty Thor is likely to kill her.
Despite the demise of the Necrosword, Gorr
still opens the doors to Eternity before he
dies, which was his goal all along.
In "Love and Thunder," Eternity is a being
at the center of the universe who will grant
the individual who finds it a single wish.
And even though he's dying, Gorr still has
enough life in him to see his plan through
to the end.
Thor and Jane follow him into Eternity, where
Jane collapses, and Thor admits Gorr has won.
Yet, it's not clear why it has to be that
way.
After all, Gorr no longer has the power of
the Necrosword, so it seems Thor could easily
kill him before he made his wish, saving himself
in the process.
Plus, with Gorr out of the way, presumably,
Gorr's wish would pass to Thor, and he could
wish Jane's cancer away, saving her and enabling
them to pursue their rekindled romance.
Instead, the pair convinces Gorr to wish for
his daughter to live instead of all gods to
die, which ensures Thor's survival, but leaves
Jane to perish.
Why would Thor choose to spare the life of
his enemy instead of killing him in cold blood?
Well, as he says in Thor: Ragnarok,
"Because that's what heroes do."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.